so meine damen und herren bei den grünen
hat gerade eine völlig neue zeitrechnung
begonnen habe und berbalk sagen servus
parteispitze die neuen heißen ricarda
lang und omid nouripour frisch gewählt
vom digitalen parteitag letzten samstag
und meine güte war das schon wieder eine
harmonie veranstaltung bei den grünen ja
mehr gute laune geht beim besten willen
nicht wobei immer zumindest ein klein
wenig wasser in die tofu suppe zu gießen
laut einer aktuellen umfrage hält nur
etwa die hälfte der grünen anhänger die
beiden neuen für die richtige wahl na
klar sie sind halt noch nicht so bekannt
ist merkt man auch bei interviews die
planungen laufen wenn druck wir viel
fehlen ihr nur 14 tagen online
mit nouripour jahrhundert wird nur was
ist denn so das was und was frau lang
jetzt anders machen wäre
sehr gute frage an den herrn nominum
tatsächlich hätten die grünen auf ihrem
glücksbärchis parteitag endlich
besprechen können warum sie monate vor
der wahl wie eine kartei da stehen um
dann als juniorpartner zu enden
spannendes thema aber dafür war wohl
keine zeit mehr nachdem man die
bisherigen vorsitzenden nochmal
ausgiebig feiern musste hier claudia
roth verabschiedet annalena baerbock mit
zitaten aus ihrer alten plattensammlung
warum auch immer du meist die heime
dream mit einem notbudget
steige
und alles leuchtet nur für dich echt
alles leuchtet der himmel ist weiß
gewann the world girls
woraufhin gegner möchte hunger zu rot q
q q q typisch grüne einen haufen zitate
aber ohne quellenangabe so können wir
sie ansonsten hat der grünen-parteitag
natürlich über die verschiedenen pläne
der partei zur transformation
deutschlands diskutiert ja zum beispiel
über die agrarwende die agrarwende die
unser neuer landwirtschaftsminister
tschetschenien plant er fordert schluss
mit den rams vor allem beim fleisch sie
haben vielleicht alle die greenpeace
studie gelesen die erst kürzlich noch
mal festgestellt
88 prozent der befragten wollen bessere
haltungsbedingungen mit weniger tieren
in den ställen
wer bitte sind die restlichen zwölf
prozent die wollen dass tiere noch
schlimmer gehalten werden wohl hier so
viele tierquäler weit über 90 prozent
der deutschen schweine leben in
geschlossenen ställen nach wie vor und
natürlich hat özdemir ist vorstoß
trotzdem den üblichen shitstorm
ausgelöst nicht umsonst heißt es ja in
artikel 1 unseres grundgesetzes
das recht auf ein künftig für 299 ist
unantastbar steht also wieso wird immer
tierwohl gegen sozialpolitik ausgespielt
man kann zum beispiel den hartz-iv-satz
signifikant erhöhen was die grünen
zumindest im wahlkampf ja noch wollten
und gleichzeitig den schweinen mehr
bewegung können inklusive
persönliche ansprache die landwirtschaft
ist handgemacht die tiere werden noch
persönlich angesprochen
wo ist die schlachte ja so ein
glückliches schweigen die rosi also
nicht mehr lange aber immerhin
inszenieren möchte die förderstrukturen
erneuern das heißt mehr platz für tiere
honorieren die landwirte müssten dafür
unter anderem stelle umbauen und fragen
sich jetzt selbstverständlich wer das
bezahlt greenpeace schlägt
beispielsweise vor die mehrwertsteuer
auf fleisch zu erhöhen und bei obst und
gemüse zu streichen so will man uns wohl
mit sanftem druck vom nacken stick zum
pastinaken steak bringen kleiner haken
steuererhöhungen wird es mit der fdp
wohl genauso wenig geben wie eine
tierwohl abgabe wie finanziert man es
dann als erstes sollten wir vielleicht
mal die wahren kosten von lebensmitteln
überhaupt zur kenntnis nehmen verdeckte
kosten zb durch gülle die wiederum unser
trinkwasser teurer macht für alle auch
für vegetarier da hat die aktion wir
haben es satt gerade mit einem sehr
schönen staffellauf darauf hingewiesen
mit einem staffellauf was
neustadt ernährungspolitik jetzt weil
wir an preise von lebensmitteln nicht
überall drauf stehen neustadt
agrarpolitik weil nur ankündigungen
nichts bringe dennoch halte er eine
zukunft faust ist es viel viel weniger
tiere gehalten werden meine güte du
musst in den lauf sprechen sonst hört
man nicht gar nicht hören in der sache
haben sie allerdings völlig recht die
uni greifswald hat neulich ausgerechnet
das hackfleisch dreimal so teuer sein
müsste um die tatsächlichen kosten zu
decken cem özdemir kämpft also für
deutsche landwirte als offizieller power
ranger damit bei denen endlich mal mehr
hängen bleibt und nicht immer nur beim
handel schafft deutschland die
agrarwende die gute nachricht manches
passiert auch von ganz alleine der
schweine fleischkonsum ist zb in den
letzten 20 jahren bei uns kontinuierlich
zurückgegangen die essen immer weniger
schwein ist ziemlich klar was das heißt
armes deutschland
nach dem ende der atomkraft und der
kohle steigen wir jetzt auch noch aus
dem schwein aus alle die sie hier sehen
sind bald arbeitslos es ist der exit aus
dem speck der gefürchtete
totale horror kinder schlafen in der
schule ein weil sie zum frühstück keine
mortadella kriegen wegen permanenter
unter wussten nähern sich deutschlands
männer gefährlich ihrem idealgewicht und
metzger gucken traurig
während sich die faulen schweine in der
karibik mit den schecks amüsieren wir
sagen stopp den speck cit jetzt eine
initiative der deutschen
fleischwirtschaft und der friedrich
ebert stiftung
schwer zu sagen ob ärzte mehr am ende
scheitert zb an den eu agrarförderung
linien der für die nächsten jahre längst
festgeschrieben sind da kann man nichts
machen in jedem fall war das ziemlich
mutig höhere lebensmittelpreise
vorzuschlagen und das mitten in einer
inflations debatte denn laut einer
aktuellen umfrage das fand ich sehr
interessant haben die deutschen gerade
vor nicht so viel angst wie vor
inflation also dem ungebremsten
preisanstieg was tun hier endlich mal
praxisnahe tipps von unserer heute schon
netz reporterinnen larissa
inflation und trotzdem spaß dabei mit
sparfuchs larissa
ja auch so traurig wie ich ja weil alles
immer teurer wird es ist ein desaster
und kanzler schulz tut nichts während
ich unterschreibe ich moore ist dieser
50 euro schein auf einmal nur noch 48
euro wert und deswegen schreibe ich mir
das am besten direkt braucht jetzt habe
ich mir verschrieben
lebensmittel werden luxus wenn ich kein
ständiger einkaufen geht dann muss ich
alles alles genau durchrechnen was ich
mir überhaupt noch leisten kann ich kann
mir wirklich nur das allernötigste
kaufen
[Musik]
dieser mantel der der sieht voll schönes
schwörer wobei sowohl ja genau also
inflation also man muss jetzt wegen den
grünen jeden cent umdrehen und jetzt
zeige ich euch tipps und tricks wie ihr
euch trotz inflation abwechslungsreich
ernähren könnt ihr kauft zum essen nur
noch
fleisch ja weil fleisch ist das einzige
lebensmittel das immer vor allem billig
bleibt wegen der subventionen
kein mensch kauft mehr gemüse weil nur
reiche leute können sich das leisten
aber ich zeige euch wie ihr euren
speiseplan vielseitig gestalten können
zum beispiel mit 1 gleich musik ein
bisschen schwein
dann was von ruhe und dann noch
irgendwas anderes von schwenk ist ein
schicker fertig in die kanten
[Applaus]
brot das ist nur was für millionäre und
er nimmt einfach salami und zwei
schnitzel
oder hier
selbst gemachte pralinen aus feinsten
mit kurzen fast gar nicht die roma
problem mal
schmeckt gut oder
seht ihr man kann auch mit inflation
sehr gut leben nur eine sache geht gar
nicht der neue menschen preisrekord ich
habe eine fordernde grün wie soll bitte
ein normaler mensch einigermaßen
bezahlbar mit dem auto zur arbeit kommt
vor allem wenn man wie stark ein auto
hat und keine arbeit
inflation und trotzdem spaß dabei mit
sparfuchs larissa
martina hill hat um eine video jetzt
fällt mir gerade ein wir haben aus
versehen eine ganze sendung ohne corona
gemacht das geht aber nicht ich glaube
das gar nicht erlaubt nein das geht
nicht denn die große lockerungs debatte
land die geht ja munter weiter und wie
ich festgestellt habe die ganzen
querdenker demos natürlich auch auf der
dem nur der impfgegner auf dem
wilhelmplatz schätzte die polizei die
teilnehmerzahl auf 15 nach angaben der
beamten sprach der veranstalter von 200
teilnehmern
einigen wir uns auf 7
ich wollte euch nur um ein kleines auto
bieten einfach anklicken
macht's gut
los
los du scheiße fährt